الراهبات الثوريات
، خيرة حراسة العقيد القذافي
المكلفات بالأعمال التي يصعب عملها على الرجال
لم يأمن العقيد للرجال
وأمن على نفسه بجانب حارساته من النساء
فالخيانة تقصم ظهر القائد
والعقيد يوقن بأن الخيانة لا تأتي إلا من الرجال
فالنساء لا تخون
والنساء كالرجال لا فرق بينهم لدى العقيد،
القذافي  حرر المرأة الليبية ورفع مكانتها أمام العالم،،،
الحراسة النسائية للعقيد القذافي
لكن قبل ذلك
لقبن بالراهبات الخضراء أو الأمازونيات
وهن الحراسة النسائية المكلفة
بحماية العقيد الليبي الراحل معمر القذافي
كان العقيد يؤمن بأن المرأة متساوية مع الرجل
في كل شيء
ويمكن لها أن تؤدي كل أدوار الرجل من دون نقص
يقول ضابط في الاستخبارات
السوفييتية
عندما زارنا القذافي ذهبنا لاستقباله في المطار
وتفاجأنا بعد نزول العقيد من الطائرة
أنه لم يكن وحيدا وكان بصحبته
، خمس حسناوات شقراوتين وسمراوتين
وأخرى فاتحة البشرة
فظن السوفييت أن العقيد زير نساء
لكن مالذي جرى بعدها؟!!!!!!،
يقول الضابط، ذهلنا عندما رأينا هؤلاء الحسناوات
مدججات بالسلاح، ويتمتعن بهيئة جسدية رياضية ملفتة،
وكانت هناك سيارة مخصصة للحرس
لكن الحسناوات لم يركبنها، وقفزن على التعليمات
وركبن بالسيارة الاحتياطية الخاصة بالتمويه
وفتحن نوافذ السيارة وأخرجن أسلحتهن
يقول أردنا أن نمنع ذلك وأبلغنا القيادة،
لكن الزعيم السوفييتي ميخائيل غورباتشوف
، أمرنا بالسماح لهم بالمرور
ويضيف عندما رأت الحسناوات أن سيارتهن تبعد كثيرا
عن سيارة العقيد، أقتربن أكثر وأكثر
حتى أصبحن بجانب سيارة العقيد
وهو ما أدهش السوفييت من جرأة مرافقات القذافي
عندما تشكلت مجموعة الحراسات النسائية
في بداية ثمانينيات القرن الماضي،
قال العقيد حينها أن توظيف الكادر النسائي مهم جدا
خصوصا أن الرجال يجدون صعوبة في إطلاق النار على النساء
بينما يسهل ذلك على بنات حواء
ويرافق العقيد ١٥ حارسة شخصية على الأقل
خلال رحلاته الداخلية
بينما يختار العقيد كادر الحراسة الخاص به وفق معايير محددة
وخاصة به
وأهمها أن لا يتعدى عمر الفتاة ٢٠ عاما
، وأن تكون عذراء غير متزوجة
حتى لا يشغلها ذلك عن عملها،
ولا يُمنع أن تتوفر على قدر من الجمال
ويُسمح باستخدام القليل من المكياج
وينبغي أن تكون الفتاة ذات قوام فارع وبنية جسدية قوية
شبيهة ببنية الرجال، وأن يكون ولاؤها المطلق للعقيد قائد الثورة
بينما يوفر العقيد لمرشحات الحراسة تدريبا وتأهيلا
عسكريا مكثف، يتخلله تدريب استخدام الأسلحة بجميع أنواعها،
والتدريب على رياضات الالتحام البدني كالجودو والكاراتيه وغيرها
وكان القذافي يطلق على حارساته جميعهن اسم عائشة
حبا وتقديرا لابنته الوحيدة عائشة
وكان العقيد يغدق على حارساته بالمال ويضاعف رواتبهن
ويجعل لهن زيارات تسوق إلى إيطاليا بين الحين والآخر،
فيما عرف ولاؤهن المطلق للعقيد فقد اختفت الحارسات
من المشهد تماما عقب حرب المحتجين
ودول التحالف على العقيد
فهل أرسلهن العقيد خوفا عليهن؟
أو مالذي جرى حينها.
(وهنا سيكون لنا موضوعا آخر عن اختفاء حارسات القذافي المفاجئ)
إيمان العقيد أحد أقوى حكام العرب في الفترة الأخيرة بالنساء
وبدورهن في المجتمع وقوتهن الخفية
التي تساوي قوة الرجال
جعله يعينهن لحراسته الشخصية
ويأمن على روحه لديهن
وقابلت الراهبات الثائرات الوفاء بمثله
فهل يستطيع أحد القادة اليوم أن يفعل ما فعله العقيد؟،،،،،